I was raid leading a guild with some of
my really really great friends some of
them are across the street and we
actually were serious enough that we
took applications and so we got a group
that you were part of so I was I was in
another guild for two years before we
applied to incarnadine are killed and I
was basically like a job interview you
know how to describe everything we had
script yeah
like seriously it was good and I
remember her mic was broken for the
voice interview you got on vent and you
would type your responses and the other
two guys would talk back so we didn't
know she was chick not that not matter
until I logged in for the first time to
show up to our first raid so I fly into
the Badlands and I'm at the group and I
hit push-to-talk on vent for the first
time I'm like hey everybody and you said
who invited the 12 year old boy pick
pick up once for the ages there
protip it's gonna say that to a girl who
was clearly a girl
and then after that people you know I
went through on the other guild forums
and everyone was posting their pictures
of what they look like and your picture
the very first picture I saw sorry very
first picture I saw of him he's on he's
he's on a car a very old car 79 Toyota
Corolla 79 Toyota Corolla that is
classic that I got for free off of
Craigslist that is currently being
rebuilt and he's and he's lifting up his
shirt and spraying his nipple with wd-40
any of them like boxing take notes
gentleman Barisan photos and derogatory
sexist comments and so for a very long
time that's all I knew of him that was
like the only photo you you had posted
for years yeah so that's that's how I
knew you what stage did this turn from
my good friend Lee to not that's a
little more than friendly yeah it took a
very long soak a very long time I
actually quit well and then came back
before we ever had it that way I found
out he had broken up with his girlfriend
for about a month and I was going
through some pretty tough times in the
relationship I was in and we had pretty
much broken up at that point and I would
always log on to make sure he was doing
okay
because they had been together for so
long it's like five five seven five
something years so I'd log on and I just
be questing leveling up a new character
doing the expansion and asked him you
know was everything right you know are
you guys talking whatever during that
doing those conversations we started you
started getting a little bit flirty I
guess I started reciprocating and that
was the time and I knew once you gave me
your phone number I was like oh yeah
there's something here I remember I
distinctly remember I graduated college
and I was at work software company and I
was talking with
one of my friends I said hey I think I'm
going to ask her if she fly up here
because I was DC Northern Virginia
already and she was she was in Fort
flown at South for him so yeah this was
this I will never forget this moment we
she flew to DC a National Airport right
right also right in DC one ounce of
whatever and she had a local carrier
MetroPCS personally yes and so my phone
didn't work outside the outside of this
certain number of states so he had to
like paste the baggage claim area to see
when I arrived and I remember walking
out of you know the arrivals tunnel
where you go into the budget claim area
and I'm kind of just walking around by
myself you know waiting and I saw the
back of your head first and I just I
just kind of recognized you I don't even
I'm not really sure I guess I'm at your
hair color a haircut
yeah and I saw the back of your head
nose I know that's him and I just I
tried to like match her gait and catch
up to you as I was following him because
he's just pacing back and forth so I try
to get catch up to him but he turns
around first and sees me and I I'm not
making this up it felt like I was hit by
lightning that like instant recognition
and it was like oh oh yeah holy crap
this is what we do for here
yeah years probably for years we read it
together for two years and then goes off
for like a year and yeah yeah but just
like boobs like that ah I've never felt
anything like that knowing that you're
talking to somebody saying that we met
like a [ __ ] video game huh oh so
what's it like talking to people who
don't even have context it it comes up a
lot
yes and over seven years the reaction
has drastically shifted at the time
people didn't understand the wide
population most people didn't understand
that you used a voice chat in a video
game yeah actually that was that was a
really bizarre concept so like the first
question was like what we're just typing
to each other and we're like well you
could you know but we also had this
voice program and after after we
explained to them that you can talk to
someone
in a video game they're just like oh
okay
you know they kind of the gears start
turning we get a lot of what Assad eyes
still a lot of sad eyes nowadays
nowadays everybody everybody's heard it
just it was just like I'm more of a
a mental connection than it was anything
else and and honestly I credit world
Warcraft for that because of not only
this relationship but some of the best
friends I've ever had
I've met three well and it was just
through chat through conversation when
you raid together especially the way we
rated um you know if someone makes a
mistake like something goes wrong we do
immediate triage what happened how do we
fix it
studio and you you take that form of
troubleshooting and you apply it to a
relationship like we don't fight much at
all raids raids themselves are like very
trying or they you know they were very
trying on a person or a group of people
so if you've already experienced
something like that together you know
you at least at the very least work well
together in a difficult situation what
do you think about world of warcraft
considering for some people that bring
some events entertainment for you guys
it's bring perhaps the most significant
part of games are like so most
significant parts as well as other parts
connecting with old friends you you're
able to keep in contact with friends you
knew since you were like 5 years old
right I've you know I've met a
significant number of friends in my life
of just through well so it's it's more
like a life-changing thing and the way
we don't currently play anymore um
nothing but I'm you know I still like
feel the the life-changing events from
it but like going to Blizzcon and seeing
how many people are changed by this gay
like think about it it's been 10 years
so this has been like an integral part
of millions of people's lives for 10
years that's huge